oh no oh no no
no what hey guys it's max we just got in
the brand new surface laptop 4 and we
not only are going to compare it against
apple's
m1 macbook air but also against the
surface laptop 4
with the amd processor so i am super
excited to see how apple's m1 compares
to intel
and amd and we're not only going to
compare things like the keyboards
trackpads
speakers webcams we're also going to
look at that cpu performance in real
world tasks
and how the thermals compare between
intel
and amd as always we have links down in
the video description and i have a link
to this m1 macbook air that you can buy
for 900 on sale right now which is crazy
and i also want to mention that you guys
can click that subscribe button down
below
that would help us out because we're
trying to reach 1 million subscribers
before the end of the year
and about 77 of you guys are not
actually yet subscribed so that would
mean
the world to us let's go and jump in and
these both weigh
2.8 pounds so as far as weight it's
identical
but you can see that the surface laptop
4 is physically
larger than the macbook air and the
biggest reason why is the display and
along with that we have some major
display differences that are quite
shocking which we'll talk about in just
a bit
and surprisingly the surface's body is
actually thinner than the macbook airs
but once you add in the lid
it is just slightly thicker overall now
as far as ports our macbook air has two
thunderbolt 4 ports so they're super
quick
whereas the surface laptop 4 has one usb
type-c
port and a usb type a port plus a
headphone jack on the left hand side
and then if we flip over to the other
side the macbook has its headphone jack
and the surface has the microsoft
surface connector which you can use to
charge and connect
docs now i have to say we are
transferring files to the surface
and unfortunately this usbc port on here
it's not thunderbolt 4
it is not thunderbolt 3 it's not even 10
gigabit per second
usb type c so our transfer was going at
a super slow
350 megabyte per second compared to my
other amd laptop
which actually transferred at about 730
so double the speed
and then of course with thunderbolt 4 on
the mac it goes at over 2000 with that
same
exact drive so that definitely is a
disappointment now the only reason why
i think they could be doing this is to
sell their very expensive
surface connector docks because you need
to use their own without thunderbolt on
this machine in order to get good speeds
so that is a major disappointment now
with their charger it actually comes
with a faster 65 watt charger
and they do give you one more usb port
both these have nice one-handed hinges
and i love that we have windows hello on
this laptop it logs you in automatically
whereas the macbook you do have to use
touch id to log
in or of course if you have an apple
watch you can do that as well now our
intel surface does have this alcantara
material that's soft touch
it is not cold to the hand so it does
feel nice feels more
cozy if you want to say that but it can
capture grease
but if you want to spend a little bit
more get a higher end version of the
surface
you actually do end up getting full
aluminum which does feel more premium as
far as keyboards the surface laptops
does feel really nice it's clicky it's
responsive
but it is not as good as the magic
keyboard on the macbook air just feels a
little bit more
tactile i would say and as far as track
pads the macbook air definitely has the
better trackpad you can't really compete
with these force touch or 3d touch track
pads
with that said even though the surface
does have a diving board design trackpad
it feels surprisingly even all around
and it is also very responsive with
microsoft's
trackpad drivers and now it's time to
compare the speakers our macbook air has
these speaker grilles
so the speakers are up firing whereas
the surface you don't see speaker
grilles anywhere so i'm sure they're
probably flying from
maybe behind the keyboard or somewhere
over there so i'm curious to see
if microsoft has made an improvement
with this new laptop
so let's go ahead and compare these and
i will say
this is going to be the last time that
we are using this song
i know a lot of you guys are tired of it
so go ahead and enjoy
hearing this song for the very last time
put on a pair of headphones and let's go
ahead
and take a listen
bring me back
all right guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below which
one sounded better and in what way
i'll give you guys my opinion i don't
think the surface laptop 4 had a speaker
upgrade
from the laptop 3. with that said it
still sounds good it is really loud for
a windows laptop
it has good bass good mids the highs
could be a little bit sharper but
overall i think anybody's going to
complain
with that said the macbook air sounds
better in every way
the vocal clarity is definitely better
it is definitely louder
the bass is also a little bit more rich
so the macbook air is definitely the
winner
and now it's compared the webcam and
microphone quality this is the quality
you can expect
from the macbook air's 720p webcam
and the built-in microphones and this is
the quality of microsoft's 720p
webcam looking at it right now it
actually looks a lot better to me
but you guys let me know which one looks
better side by side down in the comment
section below
along with which one sounded better as
far as the microphones
and now let's compare the displays where
we have a lot of differences
the first one you'll notice is that the
surface laptop 4 uses a more square
display it's a 3x2 aspect ratio
which i really like on a small 13 inch
laptop gives you a lot more usable space
16 by 10 is also not bad
now as far as detail or sharpness
the macbook air has about a 4.1 million
pixel
display nice and sharp and then here we
actually have 3.3
sounds worse but in reality this display
is much better than
a lot of 1080p displays it's nice and
sharp so as far as detail
there are no issues now this display is
also a touch screen which of course
apple does not put touch screens on
their macs now as far as brightness the
surface
is actually brighter than the macbook
air it is now
500 nits so it's brighter than before
which is great
and the macbook air is running at about
400 nits of brightness
but unfortunately microsoft did not
improve the reflectivity so it's almost
like a mirror if you're in a dark room
and
you're watching dark content or if
you're in a bright room with stuff in
the background or even outside
and along with that we also have a
really big difference in
contrast whereas the macbook air's
display is a lot more contrasty with
more accurate colors
and finally let's get into performance i
have
all three laptops here we have the amd
surface laptop four of course we have
the m1 macbook air and then the intel
surface laptop four this one right here
is the mid spec
i5 model um 11 gen but it is actually
very close to performance to the i7 we
checked online
uh and then this is actually the best
amd version of the surface laptop for
you can get i
purchased it on the business website
because they don't let you get the best
cpu
on the mainstream one for some reason so
let's go ahead and get started
i'm starting off with the speedometer
2.0 test to see
how quick and responsive the web
browsing is and
both surface laptops are actually
plugged in we will be doing one test
unplugged to see if they maintain their
performance
all right guys we are done and this is
interesting i honestly wasn't expecting
this
the amd actually got worst they got last
place
139 compared to 158 and 225 so of course
the macbook air smoked the others
it is super quick and responsive it was
actually
42 faster than the intel
laptop and then 62 faster than the amd
and then the intel was actually about a
14
or so faster or 16 than the amd and
that's because it does have
a faster single core performance
compared to
having eight actual cores in this amd
laptop
and now let's see how these cpus perform
in a variety of different tests so we're
using
geekbench five here and once again the
two surface laptops
are plugged in it's interesting the amd
is actually loud you guys can probably
hear that where these were silent and
they actually got
done first which is really weird all
right we have our scores
and now i know why the fans were
spinning
up we have a score of 7096
multi-core that is by far the fastest
i've ever seen
in a windows ultrabook that is
incredible
and it smokes the 5018
that our intel model got with the 11th
gen
which is actually quite good of a score
for a laptop
this size but neither of those compared
to the 7641
of our macbook air which did it
completely silently
so we only have a difference about 7.6
percent
between the amd and the m1 but the amd
is about 36 percent faster
than the intel now that does not tell
the whole story
first off they are both plugged in the
two surface laptop fours
we're going to test that in a sec
unplugging them but if we look at the
single core
the amd gets absolutely smoked by the
other two we have
172 compared to 1327 and then a massive
1743 for the m1 this is probably why web
browsing is so much faster and snappier
with the m1
it is 31 faster than the intel system as
far as single core
and 49 faster than the amd
which is absolutely crazy and now
let's go ahead and we are going to
unplug
the 65 watt power adapters and i'm gonna
go run this
one more time all right so we are
running and i want to show you guys that
i do have the best performance
selected on these machines and with that
now that it's on battery power uh this
amd
surface laptop 4 is staying completely
silent
which might not be good news alright we
have our scores
and yep i was right
that is not good news we got a score of
5 700 instead of 7096 almost 70
100 we definitely are getting a fairly
decent drop in performance
on the amd system now as far as the
intel
it did drop but less than 100 points
so not bad at all and then as far as
single core
actually got a little bit higher here on
battery power
but once again on the amd system we have
953
that is the slowest i've seen in years
and that is a drop of about 23 percent
uh kind of on both right there 23 25
that's pretty terrible and of course the
m1 was unplugged the whole time
and it just absolutely smokes these
machines
when it's unplugged no issues whatsoever
and now i'm running the graphics test
because i want to see how good
are these amd integrated graphics and
both of the surface laptop fours are
plugged in
so we're not going to be trying to
hamper their performance we'll keep them
plugged in for this
all right we have our results and this
is actually good news
the amd got 15 07
which is really good compared to 15
032 pretty much the same score
and this does have the best g7 graphics
intel xe which they actually just got
this good of performance very recently
before it was much
worse but of course the m1 macbook air
got
19 065 it beat out these other two
and keep in mind this is the seven core
model and of course it is also unplugged
if you spend about 50 bucks
more you can get the 8 core model which
gets 21
up to 22 000 you know what guys i wanted
to test out unplugged performance
i said i wasn't going to do it i want to
see as far as graphics
can amd keep up this level of graphics
performance that was quite impressive
all right
oh no oh no no
no what oh no okay are you kidding
um uh it's on best performance okay
no amd no that's horrible
we well you guys can see it got eight
thousand four hundred forty eight
it's not half the performance but it's
close dude it's a joke
and the surface just got done fourteen
thousand seven hundred so
the intel system barely lost performance
it lost about
i don't know what is that three hundred
three to four hundred
compared to this it went from fifteen
thousand to
eight thousand four hundred wow all
right guys now we're to push the
machines to their limits we're going to
test thermals
so i want to get a baseline reading i
have my thermal camera here
and let's take a look at the amd system
it's idling at 31 degrees
celsius and i'm gonna go to the intel
30 degrees celsius so it actually is
running slightly cooler
and then our m1 mac look at that color
difference
so m on mac is at 27 degrees at the
hottest point and that's actually
what is that the display portion
interesting yeah it's actually the
display portion right there
definitely cooler but we're going to
take a look once we actually start
running these
and let's go ahead and get started with
our 10 minute multi-core stress test
it's going to push all these systems to
their
limits and unfortunately i opened up my
hardware monitor here
and it is not telling me the wattage or
even the frequency of the cpu here
we can see that it jumped up to 80
degrees celsius pretty quickly there
and then on the intel system it's
running at 83 84 degrees celsius
and all the way up to looks like 39
almost 40 watts
that is actually really high wattage for
a machine like this
which is maybe why it gets such good
performance all right so looks like
we're actually getting 3.1 gigahertz
across
eight cores compared to about 3.3
3.4 for the intel's four cores i don't
know if you guys can hear that the amd's
fans kicked up
it's definitely loud whereas the macbook
air is completely solid no fan
in the intel system even at now 30 watts
it is very very quiet all right the
intel system is actually speeding up now
i can hear the fan and it's different
it's a lot higher pitch than the amd
version even though it's the same laptop
and our m1 macbook air is running at 83
degrees celsius
so right around the same compared to the
other two so it's been eight minutes so
far and it's interesting that the intel
laptop is actually
louder now than the amd this got quieter
that means it's cutting down the wattage
to keep itself running cool and i really
wish i could see the wattage but let's
grab our thermal camera
looks like the amd is running at 42
celsius
and the intel is running at 44 even
hotter
wow and then our m1 is at
39 to 40. they're right there at the
edge
of course it's fanless all right we are
done and this is a nice
reversal we have 8 33
for the amd system compared to 7687
compared to the m1 macbook pro
that means that if you're pushing cpu
all the way
it actually gets seven to eight percent
higher performance than the m1 mac
which is exactly the same but opposite
compared to geekbench five
where the mac was seven eight percent
faster and that is with
amd definitely slowing down somewhere in
the middle of that test to keep itself
from running too hot so that's excellent
performance
when it's plugged in and of course the
intel is in last place
5038 points meaning
the amd version of the surface laptop 4
with this best cpu is 65
faster than the intel as long as you can
keep it plugged in
and now let's see how those performance
numbers actually act out
in real world programs i have adobe
lightroom classic opened here
with some 42 megapixel raw images with a
bunch of effects
and we know from the past that even
though this program is not
written for apple silicon it's running
under rosetta
the performance is actually the same the
smoothness when we're switching photos
brushes all that stuff so now i'm
wondering how does this amd cpu hold up
so first i'm going to do is just switch
through
about the same
so sometimes m1 slightly faster like
that
there you go so either about the same or
maybe the m1 being slightly faster but
it's pretty close
and now i'm going to go ahead and select
all of these images here all 50 of them
and we are going to do an export test
now as we wait i do want to mention that
both these systems the intel
surface laptop 4 and the macbook air
have 8 gigabytes of ram
compared to 16 gig on this high-end amd
version which
they make you get 16 gigabytes um now
the previous tests we did didn't really
really matter that much as far as
the amount of ram because uh as long as
you don't have stuff open in the
background it's enough for it but
lightroom is heavily dependent on ram
performance so we're going to see how
this unified ram can compete
with 16 gig wow this is interesting the
intel
is actually going faster than the amd
even though has weaker performance less
ram and it's actually louder
as well but it looks like the m1 is
still sped up there
and it's gonna finish first and bam the
intel actually beat out the amd
and yes the amd is still plugged in this
is insane
and there is the last one so looks like
our macbook took
two minutes and 33 seconds the intel
took
two minutes and 55 seconds and the amd
took three minutes and 16 seconds
which is crazy because as you guys saw
it has the best cpu performance but
in this real world photo editing test
it is actually the slowest that is
insane
but now let's see what we get with video
editing i have
the latest version of davinci resolve
studio opened up right here with some 4k
footage
with some luts and effects let's test
out our playback performance
i'm going to hit the spacebar on all of
these and let's mute this guy right here
and it looks like on the m1 it's playing
back perfectly
look how choppy that was on the amd and
also on the intel
both look like they are having a good
amount of stuttering even though we have
good graphics performance good cpu
performance
interesting okay i'm gonna do one more
test here before we export i'm gonna go
to my color tab
here it's going to give us some more
info and now we could see that it's
playing back at about
20 21 frames per second 19 there
right around there instead of 24 and
with the intel
1817 so yes the intel is actually a
little bit slower
but neither one of these can play this
back perfectly which is really
surprising
whereas our m1 no issues not even a
single stutter
and keep in mind these two windows
laptops are plugged in
so you know there's no performance
issues the amd would slow down quite a
bit if it was unplugged and now let's
export this five minute 4k project we're
comparing
intel's quick sync compared to the m1
chips hardware encoders
and amd's dedicated encoders over here
so it's really cool
that it is using that special encoder
let's go
and we'll see what we get and the
macbook air is speeding through this
we have just a few seconds remaining
here
all right it looks like it took two
minutes and 58 seconds to get done
we still have four minutes and five
seconds remaining here
and four minutes and 30 seconds
remaining with the intel
it took seven minutes and 27 seconds
compared to seven minutes and 12 seconds
and the m1 macbook air took two minutes
and 58
seconds more than twice as fast it could
have lapped these two
all while being completely silent i'm
sure you guys can hear these fans here
they're both coming along and it is just
silent no issues and it just is insanely
fast that is absolutely incredible
and the other thing that is incredible
is that even though this amd system is
so much faster
with the multi-core performance and it
is plugged in it would be much slower if
we unplugged it
the intel is just barely behind
and it's also quite a bit cheaper as
well which is just kind of crazy
and mind-blowing so with all of that
said what did we learn
well first off even though we have eight
cores here with the amd system
and the fans kick up sooner and it runs
louder and hotter
real world performance isn't that much
better in fact in lightroom it was
actually slower
and for video editing it was just
slightly faster and then if you unplug
it it is just much slower especially
with the graphics
so the intel system being cheaper i
would actually suggest in this case
going with the intel system and along
with that
the m1 macbook air is an absolute boss
it is by far
cheaper than the other two even if
you're matching up the same amount of
ram and ssd
and you can actually pick one up right
now for 900
899 bucks i'll have a link and down in
the video description
and it is silent and it just smokes
these other two
especially in the real world performance
it is absolutely
incredible so there you guys go let me
know your thoughts down in the comment
section below go ahead and click that
subscribe button above to help us reach
our goal of 1 million subscribers before
the end of the year
we would greatly greatly appreciate it
and check out one of those other videos
right over
there that's been max and i'll see you
in the next video